Карати жорстко і агресивно.
Київська влада посилює боротьбу з порушниками правил паркування.
До комунальних евакуаторів, які не перший місяць працюють на вулицях столиці,
доєдналися ще й приватні.
Вони здатні прибрати автівку з проїжджої частини за лічені хвилини.
Процес повністю автоматизований.
І якщо ще два місяці тому вони звільняли від припаркованих автівок
смуги громадського транспорту переважно в центрі Києва,
тепер щоденно навідуються і до спальних районів столиці.
Тут навіть в обідню пору робочого дня ніде яблуку впасти.
Запарковані тротуари, газони, дороги. Автівки кидають просто посеред проїжджої частини.
Дуже він некрасиво стоїть. Він заважає дорожньому руху.
Звісно, порушує правила дорожнього руху, тобто даний автомобіль буде евакуйовано.
- Номер телефону, це якось діє?
Ви розумієте, для нас якби діє, що він може прибрати, але ж заважає,
а тут знаходиться дитяча поліклініка.
Якщо кожному дзвонити… Ви розумієте.
Головний аргумент водіїв - паркуватися ніде.
А куди ж її ставити? Я поставив не на переході, а правіше від переходу.
Ну, звісно, не за правилами. Де мені взяти ті 10 метрів?
От пішов на півгодини додому. Вийшов, немає машини.
Дякую за "зручності" для громадян України.
Водночас, попри нарікання на брак парковок,
у денний час великі платні парковки, приміром, посеред житлового масиву Позняки майже порожні.
Водії надають перевагу паркуванню вздовж доріг задарма.
Подібне відбувається і в центрі міста.
Окрім інспекторів з паркування й поліції,
до боротьби за порядок на дорогах регулярно долучаються й активісти.
У руху "Зупини лося" в арсеналі лише один інструмент - наліпки.
Як тільки ти цьому порушнику показуєш просту наліпку,
яка жодним чином не шкодить його майно, до людини одразу доходить.
Чомусь це єдиний спосіб впливу на порушників.
І дуже часто наліпки і суспільного розголосу вони дуже часто бояться навіть більше, ніж поліції,
і більше, ніж штрафів.
Активісти виходять на рейди щотижня.
Просять водіїв не порушувати, клеять наклейки на скло автомобілів,
знімають усе на відео, яке потім розміщують на своєму ютуб-каналі.
Боротьбу з незаконним паркуванням на смузі громадського транспорту
розпочинають з тих, хто вже її заблокував.
Так протираємо, це нічого не заважає, не обмежує його огляд, і всі розуміють, що це порушник.
Поки так.
Часом до наклеювання навіть не доходить.
Деякі водії дослухаються до прохань не порушувати і одразу від'їжджають.
Добрий день. Тролейбус їде, не може через вас проїхати.
Через мене?
Так, саме через вас.
Тоді все, бігом.
Все, відходимо. Дякую вам!
Проте є й такі, що пускають у хід кулаки.
Собі покладіть.
Під час рейду з’ясовується, чому попри наявність великого платного паркінгу поблизу,
водії так масово запарковують смугу громадського транспорту.
А все тому, що ось моя робота!
Навіщо мені паркуватися за три квартали, якщо я можу тут припарковуватися.
Нічого страшного, а мені тут зручніше, мені комфортніше тут, біля офіса.
Зважаючи на таку "готовність" деяких київських водіїв використовувати офіційні паркінги,
практично немає сенсу зводити у столиці нові майданчинки для паркування,
застерігає експерт з транспортного моделювання Дмитро Беспалов.
Таким чином боротися з проблемою автомобілів у місті - це все одно, що гасити пожежу бензином.
Тобто це не дасть бажаного ефекту.
А то навіть ефект буде гірший насправді: більше транзитного трафіку,
більше заторів, якщо ми задовольнимо весь цей попит на паркування.
У Київській міській держадміністрації попереджають:
вже найближчим часом кількість евакуаторів та інспекторів з паркування зросте щонайменше вдвічі,
а з ними і шанси на штраф та потрапляння запаркованих з порушеннями автівок
на штрафмайданчик.
Кожен наступний наш крок буде тільки жорсткішим,
тільки важчим для водіїв, тому що лояльність вже закінчується.
І ми вже розпочали діяти більш агресивно.
За підрахунками Дмитра Рахматулліна,
бюджет міста від сплати за паркування міг би щорічно поповнюватися на 300 мільйонів гривень.
Але наразі це - лише теорія.
Адже подбавши про аж 11 способів оплати парковки
(від готівки в таксоматі до додатку, смс-повідомлень та qr-кодів),
міська влада водночас за рік так і не спромоглася запустити в роботу
ефективний механізм контролю цієї сплати.
Тендер на розробку програмного забезпечення
та постачання обладнання безуспішно триває вже майже рік.
Тож де-факто, чи оплатив водій парковку свого автомобіля, наразі практично ніхто не перевіряє.
І це, на думку експертів, основна причина хаотичного паркування в Києві.
Я сподіваюсь, невдовзі буде закуплене обладнання, тоді за паркування будуть платити в місті Києві.
Це, я вас запевняю, змінить все насправді.
Ми почнемо рахувати гроші і думати, чи їхати на автівці до центру міста.
Це створить додатковий попит на громадський транспорт,
і дуже важливо, щоб місто в той самий момент забезпечило пропозицію громадського транспорту,
бо зараз в Києві громадський транспорт супероптимізований.
Аби відрегулювати надмірний попит на паркомісця та зменшити кількість автівок,
залишених у середмісті з порушенням правил дорожнього руху,
столичні чиновники хочуть ще й підняти ціни на паркування.
Мовляв, якщо водіям важко знайти вільне місце для паркування,
значить, паркувальний тариф занизький.
Раніше представники міської влади
озвучували новий тариф на рівні 30-50 грн за годину паркування в центрі.
Тепер, коли вибори міського голови все ближче, конкретні цифри не називають.
Експерти й активісти наголошують: окрім комфорту та мобільності,
лад у паркуванні в Києві треба навести якомога швидше
ще й тому, що щороку в ДТП в столиці гине близько 150 людей.
Причиною смерті частини з них є неправильно припарковані авто,
що обмежують видимість для водіїв, зокрема на перехрестях і пішохідних переходах.